Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Six: immigration to Denmark through the ages.
The Danish population is relatively homogeneous.
That means most have the same language, culture and history.
Even so, people from other countries have settled permanently in the country through the ages.
They have come, among other reasons, as refugees, to work, or because they have married a Dane.
This is many hundreds of years of immigration, which has put a certain mark on the Danish population, the Danish language and Danish culture.
Immigration to Denmark has, however, been by far the biggest in recent times.
Especially over the last decades, the number of immigrants and descendants of immigrants in Denmark has risen markedly: from about 150,000 in 1980 to one million in 2025, corresponding to 16.7 percent of Denmark's total population of six million, in other words roughly one in six.
The Jews are an example of a minority that has been in Denmark for a long time.
The first Jews came to Denmark in the 1600s at the invitation of the king.
The Jews got a mixed reception and existence, and to get a residence permit they had to pay a large sum of money and submit to stricter legislation than the rest of the population.
At the end of the 1700s, about 1,600 Jews lived in Copenhagen.
The Jews gradually got more rights, and with the so-called Jewish Letter of Freedom, the "Jødiske Frihedsbrev", in 1814, the Jews were almost made equal with other Danes.
At the beginning of the 1900s, a further approximately 3,000 Jews arrived in Denmark.
They were fleeing poverty and persecution in Russia.
In time the Jews became an accepted and well-integrated part of Danish society.
Among other things, that is why by far most Danish Jews were helped to Sweden by Danish fellow citizens in 1943 during Nazi Germany's occupation of Denmark.
Thereby they avoided the same extensive genocide as the Jews in the war's other German-controlled areas.
In the time around the Second World War, it was especially war refugees who came to Denmark.
The biggest group was the just under 240,000 war refugees from Germany, who came at the end of or right after the occupation, in 1945.
In addition, around 23,000 war refugees came especially from the Soviet Union and the Baltic countries, Estonia, Latvia and Lithuania.
At the end of the 1940s, the vast majority of these refugees had however returned to their home countries.
In the first decades after the Second World War, it was first and foremost refugees from the East European countries who came to Denmark.
Hungarian refugees came as a result of the uprising in Hungary in 1956, Czechoslovaks who fled during the Soviet invasion of Czechoslovakia in 1968, and Polish Jews who were forced to leave Poland because of an antisemitic wave in the country in 1968 to 69.
Immigration in the 1960s was however in particular marked by guest workers from especially Turkey, Pakistan and the former Yugoslavia.
They met a great need for foreign labour on the Danish labour market.
A large part settled permanently in Denmark and later got their families to the country.
That was namely still possible despite the stop for immigration that was introduced in 1973.
In the 1970s, 1980s and 1990s, refugees again came to Denmark.
These were not least refugees from the war between Iraq and Iran, 1980 to 88, and the civil war in Yugoslavia, 1991 to 95.
In addition, refugees also came from, among other places, Vietnam, Sri Lanka, Somalia, and Palestinian refugees, who especially fled the civil war in Lebanon.
Between 2000 and 2020, people especially from Afghanistan, the Middle East and Africa arrived, fleeing war and poverty.
The number of asylum seekers who came to Europe and Denmark reached a peak during the so-called refugee crisis, where in total 21,000 sought asylum in Denmark in 2015.
The biggest group had fled the civil war in Syria.
In addition, in the same period many more foreigners have also come to Denmark to work.
They have come from all over the world, but the majority from other EU countries.
The number of immigrants and descendants from other EU countries has risen from 116,000 in 2000 to 318,000 in 2026.
EU citizens have the right to freely work in other EU countries, and the majority of the increase can be attributed to the EU's enlargements in 2004, 2007 and 2013 with a total of 11 East European countries.
These have meant that many East Europeans have moved to Western Europe, including Denmark, where wages are generally higher and living conditions better.
Since Russia's invasion of Ukraine in February 2022, a large number of Ukrainians have arrived in Denmark.
As of the first of January 2026, 44,000 displaced persons from Ukraine live in Denmark.
Turkey, with 68,000, is the country most immigrants and descendants originate from.
The ten countries that most immigrants and descendants in Denmark originate from are, in January 2026, thus Turkey, 68,000.
Ukraine, 59,000.
Poland, 57,000.
Romania, 47,000.
Syria, 46,000.
Germany, 45,000.
Iraq, 35,000.
Pakistan, 29,000.
Iran, 29,000.
And Lebanon, 28,000.
Of these, Poland, with 57,000, is the biggest origin country within the EU, ahead of Romania and Germany; Turkey, Ukraine, Syria, Iraq, Pakistan, Iran and Lebanon are not EU countries.
Here is your recap for Episode Six.
Immigrants and descendants grew from about 150,000 in 1980 to one million in 2025, which is 16.7 percent of six million.
The first Jews came in the 1600s at the king's invitation; the Jewish Letter of Freedom was in 1814; about 3,000 Jews came in the early 1900s from Russia.
Most Danish Jews were helped to Sweden in 1943.
Almost 240,000 war refugees came from Germany in 1945.
Hungarian refugees came after 1956, Czechoslovaks in 1968, and Polish Jews in 1968 to 69.
Guest workers in the 1960s came from Turkey, Pakistan and the former Yugoslavia; the immigration stop was in 1973.
In the refugee crisis, 21,000 sought asylum in 2015, mostly from Syria.
EU immigrants and descendants grew from 116,000 in 2000 to 318,000 in 2026, after EU enlargements in 2004, 2007 and 2013.
44,000 displaced Ukrainians lived in Denmark on the first of January 2026.
The biggest origin countries in 2026 are Turkey, Ukraine, Poland, Romania, Syria, Germany, Iraq, Pakistan, Iran and Lebanon.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which group of citizens was helped, in their thousands, to flee from Denmark to Sweden in October 1943?
Option A: Danish communists.
Option B: Danish soldiers.
Option C: Danish Jews.
[DA] Hvilken gruppe borgere blev i tusindtal hjulpet med at flygte fra Danmark til Sverige i oktober 1943?  A: Danske kommunister  |  B: Danske soldater  |  C: Danske jøder
The answer is C: Danish Jews.
It appeared in the November 2020 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danske jøder
Question 2.
From which of the following countries did the most immigrants come to Denmark in the 1960s?
Option A: Hungary.
Option B: Turkey.
Option C: Vietnam.
[DA] Fra hvilket af følgende lande kom der flest indvandrere til Danmark i 1960’erne?  A: Ungarn  |  B: Tyrkiet  |  C: Vietnam
The answer is B: Turkey.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Tyrkiet
Question 3.
From which country did over 200,000 war refugees come to Denmark in connection with the Second World War?
Option A: France.
Option B: Germany.
Option C: Russia.
[DA] Fra hvilket land kom der over 200.000 krigsflygtninge til Danmark i forbindelse med 2. Verdenskrig?  A: Frankrig  |  B: Tyskland  |  C: Rusland
The answer is B: Germany.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Tyskland
Question 4.
Which of the following countries do the most immigrants and descendants in Denmark originate from?
Option A: Pakistan.
Option B: Iran.
Option C: Turkey.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende lande har flest indvandrere og efterkommere i Danmark oprindelse i?  A: Pakistan  |  B: Iran  |  C: Tyrkiet
The answer is C: Turkey.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Tyrkiet
Question 5.
Which EU country do the most immigrants and descendants in Denmark originate from?
Option A: Spain.
Option B: Poland.
Option C: France.
[DA] Hvilket EU-land har flest indvandrere og efterkommere i Danmark oprindelse i?  A: Spanien  |  B: Polen  |  C: Frankrig
The answer is B: Poland.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Polen
Question 6.
From which country did especially many asylum seekers come to Denmark in 2015?
Option A: Syria.
Option B: Iran.
Option C: Ukraine.
[DA] Fra hvilket land kom der særligt mange asylansøgere til Danmark i 2015?  A: Syrien  |  B: Iran  |  C: Ukraine
The answer is A: Syria.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Syrien
That's the end of this part.
Well done.